willkommen zu meinem heutigen video
leute ich hab mir zu meiner rechten ein
mini tischtennis zwei kleine schläge
eine normale wahl und ein netz ein
tischtennis netz machte heute machen
luca sebastian und ich spielen ein
kleines turnier und gucken wer der beste
tischtennisspieler das alles abgespielt
ich würde mal sagen
dafür spielen gegen juve wegen wir
direkt mit auf merkt man live für die
besten tischtennisspieler aller
[Applaus]
sportlichkeit
weil höhere altersgrenzen spielt als
mädchen auf jeden fall warten
die gute meldung 1 0 für den berühmten
und nicht hübschen fpk 30
[Musik]
daran dürfen das kennt man ja
für diejenigen wir auch drei behinderten
nach 138 heute gemacht spürten funke ist
hier schon gewonnen aber das werden des
edersees spielfilmen
lukas stadt essen bestellt dass es eben
angekommen und aufgenommen
ich habe essen geliefert bekommen und
die waren so lieb und haben wir also wie
der reiche katar haben immer gold werden
daran glaubt aber an der karriere an
muss ich mag wirklich die uns wohl nie
werden drinks zu sich nehmen danach
danken lukas essen bestellt kommt ihre
feinde runde jetzt entscheidend auf
entweder jeder einmal verloren einmal
gewonnen hat oder sebastian wer es
gesagt
jenson button das team der liga vom
heutigen tag ist in dem er zwei mächtig
bin natürlich kein druck für die drei
bekannten pflanze loßburg 883 machen
da wird aus der höhe zu treiben
[Musik]
brauchst du mitgebracht hilmar
riemenschneider
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo leute den berühmten hier seht ihr
den berühmten gummibällen bringt heute
insgesamt bedeutet das übrigens ich hab
kein match gewonnen auf meine eigenen
kanal leute das ist eine leistung
sebastian 23 gewonnen und luca einmal
feuerkraft vor jeglicher also diesmal
mit kaká hätte besser gefallen lassen
für mich verrückt